le cri du coeur des chauffeurs d'autobus
de montréal a été entendue radio canada
a appris que la stm va accélérer
l'installation de caméras de
surveillance dans les autobus qui
circulent
après 23 heures ils ont serons tous
munis d'ici un an et demi ils refusent
les syndicats réclament ses caméras pour
lutter contre les gars les agressions
envers ces chauffeurs en effet de
revendications importantes syndicat des
chauffeurs pascal est ce que nous avons
appuyé cette semaine c'est que la
société de transport de montréal
procédera au rétro aménagement de vue
autobus 400 au total pour y installer
des caméras de surveillance et ça coûte
10 mille dollars par autobus pascal
installé ses caméras
le syndicat s'en réjouit et affirme
qu'il ya environ 200 agression par année
dans ses autobus et certaines sont plus
violentes que d'autres
sauvagement agressé au volant de son
autobus mélissa retournent au travail
après une convalescence de trois ans et
un client mécontent parce qu'elle ne
devait cette épreuve m'a frappé j'ai
reçu un coup de poing au visage
assez pour que j'aille à un traumatisme
crânien dislocation de la mâchoire
double luxation maintenant changeur dans
le métro de montréal
elle est protégée par une vitre pare
balles en tant que chauffeur
elle aurait aimé être protégé par une
caméra de surveillance
malheureusement il y en avait pas puis
personnes et rester pour témoigner
donc tout ce que j'ai fait un sac à dos
rouge et une casquette en mai mois aucun
passager subitement une non aucun son
talent et où prendre le prochain autobus
qui arrivaient pour prendre la relève
depuis des mois les chauffeurs de la
société de transport de montréal
revendique que minimalement tous les
autobus qui circulent après 23h soit
muni de caméras après avoir dit la chose
impossible à court terme
la stm a trouvé cette semaine près de 3
millions de dollars pour installer des
caméras dans 300 autobus 2014 si tout ce
qu'on fait on va en appel d'offres on
reçoit les instrumentations et on
commence à débuter je voudrais les
installations donc sur 300 véhicules
supplémentaires des ça ça peut prendre
quelques beaux donc ça pour être début
oui tout à fait réel de façon
raisonnable auquel une nouvelle bien
accueillie par les chauffeurs mais leurs
syndicats revendiquent toujours que
d'ici 2015
la stm utilisent davantage la nuit les
autobus déjà munis de caméras ces
caméras là ont été achetés sont payés
par vous sont payés par mois par les
usagers et les autobus d'hommes d'un
garage la nuit alors ce qu'on voudrait
c'est qui c'est qui circulent il est
difficile de faire mieux
réplique la stm quant à mélissa elle
applaudit la venue de nouvelles caméras
il est optimiste contente parce que je
veux retourner travailler sur le terrain
je sais je sincèrement j'adore faire ce
métier là
puis j'irai tellement avec le coeur
léger la tête tranquille donc
mi 2015 ce matin l'heure est passée 2015
la stm installera graduellement des
caméras dans tous ces autobus louis
philippe ouimet radio canada montréal